[Musique]
un peu plus de six mois maintenant que
les temps sont difficiles pour cette
société d'abattage de volailles
habituellement l'abattoir vend entre
1200 et 1500 volailles par semaine
aujourd'hui les ventes ont chuté à 400
pour les mauvaises semaines 800 quand
l'actualité n'évoque plus la grippe
aviaire en france pour moment il n'y a
pas de risques parce que
tout est contrôlé il ya les services
sanitaires et vétérinaires les éleveurs
sont que trop d fréquemment donc je
pense pas qu'il risque de son psy coude
quoi
il ya une peur c'est clair il ya une
peur donc on s'achemine dessus que ça
joue sur son moral les consommateurs
depuis quelques mois deviennent plus
prudents des affichettes ont été posées
à côté de la caisse afin de les rassurer
mais beaucoup d'eux mêmes préfèrent
directement interpellé les employés
quand j'entends temps en temps way 10
qui a pas de souci et pas de problème
chant des sirènes discussions d'apporter
sa peau verte
80% des transactions de cette entreprise
concerne directement le poulet un
véritable manque à gagner depuis que la
grippe aviaire fait des victimes dans le
monde depuis les vacances d'été cet
établissement à travailler seulement six
semaines pleines notamment pendant le
ramadan et les festivités de noël
le gérant s'est donc séparé de certains
collaborateurs et à peu près 50 à 60 %
de pertes depuis le mois de
septembre donc on a dû séparer de deux
employés et ce ne sont pas que les
sociétés d'abattage qui souffre déjà
certains des négociants avec lesquels il
avait l'habitude de travailler ont mis
la clé sous la porte
son entreprise est d'ailleurs en vente
même si la grippe aviaire n'est pas
forcément la raison il
c'est toute la filière qui va fermer
c'est d'aliments jusqu'au jusqu'au
consommateur quoi donc
c'est toute la filière c'est à dire les
éleveurs toute la filière
[Musique]